- [Instructor] Ancient Greece was not even
a cohesive empire.
It was made up of many city states,
led by Athens and Sparta.
But, despite its fragmentation,
it's made innumerable
contributions to, not
just Western civilization,
but civilization as a whole.
And those are contributions in terms of
forms of governance, like democracy,
contributions in medicine,
contributions in the arts,
in mathematics, in the sciences.
But perhaps their most famous contribution
is in terms of philosophy.
And if we're going to
talk about philosophy
in ancient Greece, the most
famous three philosophers
are Socrates, Plato, and Aristotle.
Now, before we get into the first of them,
and really the teacher of Plato,
who was then the teacher of Aristotle,
let's get a little bit of
context on this time period.
So, as we enter into
the fifth century BCE,
a couple of things are emerging.
First, you have a new Athenian democracy.
Then, as you get into that
century, the Persians invade,
try to conquer Greece several
times, but unsuccessfully.
But then, the Greeks start
fighting amongst themselves,
led on one side by Athens,
on the other side by Sparta,
and that's the Peloponnesian
War, which ends with
Sparta being victorious, but
all of the Greek city states
being weakened dramatically.
Now, between the end,
especially the first part
of the Greco-Persian
Wars, and the end of the
Peloponnesian War, it
was actually a time of
Athenian prosperity.
They were leading this semi-empire,
they were investing in the arts,
and it's often called
the Golden Age of Athens,
and that's the world in
which Socrates emerged.
Like many philosophers,
Socrates led a very
interesting life, and it's worth noting
what we know about him
does not come directly
from his writing.
We don't have surviving
accounts of his writing.
It comes mainly through the
writing of his students,
Xenophon, and, most notably, Plato.
We also get some parody of
Socrates from Aristophanes,
that Socrates himself
did not appreciate much.
But what we know is
that he started in life,
he was a stone mason,
he even acted as a soldier, a hoplite,
during the Peloponnesian War.
But he is, of course, most
famous for being a philosopher
and for being a teacher.
And his teaching style,
the Socratic method,
is still viewed as something
of a best practice today.
Rather than lecturing
students, to, instead,
ask incisive questions that
force a student to deepen
their thinking and get closer
to the root of an issue,
and to learn how to think
rather than just having
knowledge transmitted to them.
Now, what's also notable about Socrates
and his many students,
including Plato and Aristotle,
is that they took a departure
of how to think about
the world from most of the ancient world.
Most of the ancient world
was focused on the gods
and the metaphysical
explaining everything.
And, while the ancient Greeks
did have a large pantheon
of gods, Socrates and
his fellow philosophers
tried to figure out how the world works,
why we are here, somewhat
independent of the gods.
They tried to reason it through,
they tried to talk it
through, think about it
from a rational point of view.
And to get a flavor of
that, here is a quote.
"True wisdom comes to
each of us when we realize
"how little we understand
about life, ourselves,
"and the world around us."
So, unlike many ancient
societies that just tried to
explain everything
through the metaphysical
or through the gods, here
you have Socrates saying, no,
an ideal true wisdom
is when you appreciate how little we know,
this form of intellectual humility.
Now, Socrates lived during
this Golden Age of Athens,
a time when democracy was
flourishing, the Age of Pericles.
But he himself was a little bit skeptical
of unfettered or pure democracy.
He was worried, well,
what if the people voting
aren't educated to make
the types of decisions?
Maybe they can be
manipulated by a demagogue,
someone who just tells 'em
exactly what they want to hear.
And so he was a bit of
a controversial figure,
especially as you get to the
end of the Peloponnesian War.
Remember, Athens loses
the Peloponnesian War.
It went from being this powerful
head of this Delian League,
something of an empire, this wealthy city,
and now it's a subjugated
state, it's tired from war.
And so you can imagine there's a lot of
political infighting, and
Socrates ends up being
one of the casualties.
He is actually put on trial
by his fellow Athenians.
This is a depiction of
the trial of Socrates,
and it shows Socrates defending himself
from the accusations brought against him.
Refusing to recognize the gods
acknowledged by the state,
importing strange divinities of his own,
corrupting the young.
And his defense, which both
Xenophon and Plato write about,
called The Apology, he's
bewildered, he says,
where is all of this coming from?
Now, it is true, he
did not invoke the gods
when he's trying to explain the universe.
And, yes, he was trying to
teach the young to think.
But by no means, if you
look at what he was doing,
or at least our modern
accounts coming through Plato
and Xenophon, does it
seem like he was trying to
undermine the state in some way.
But, needless to say, it comes to a vote,
and maybe he's a victim of his own fears
of a pure democratic process,
but, amongst the 500 Athenians voting,
280 say that he is guilty,
and 220 say that he is not guilty.
He is given a chance to think about
what his penalty should be.
And the charges, at least
in the Athenian's minds,
were quite serious.
But Socrates famously says,
"An unexamined life is not worth living."
And so, even though many
historians think that
he might have been able to
get exile if he asked for it,
he was sentenced to death.
And this is a painting
done much, much later
of what that death of Socrates
might have looked like.
But you see here Socrates about
to, or maybe he just drank
the hemlock, which is the
poison which will kill him.
So, even though he had to
die for these pretty spurious
allegations, his legacy lives on,
and it lives on most famously
in his student Plato.
Now, Plato is famous for many things.
There's this notion of a
Platonic ideal form that,
whether you're talking about a circle,
or a ball, or a dog, or a chair,
that there's an ideal
form that is independent
of what your senses are telling you,
or what the chair in
front of you might be,
that that's an imperfect
version of that ideal form.
The word Platonic, in
general, you'll hear applied
to many different concepts,
some of the meanings
having changed over time.
The other thing that Plato is famous for
is the notion of an academy.
The place where he taught his students
was a little field outside
the walls of Athens,
named for the Athenian hero Akademos,
and so that area became
known as Plato's Academy.
And ever since then, places
of learning have often been
referred to as academies,
just like Khan Academy.
But Plato was also concerned,
like his teacher Socrates,
with the nature of how we should be ruled.
"There will be no end to
the troubles of states,
"or indeed of humanity
itself, till philosophers
"become rulers in this
world, or till those
"we now call kings and
rulers really and truly
"become philosophers, and
political power and philosophy
"thus come into the same hands."
So, like Socrates, he's weary of how
they have been governed.
And, remember, we're now after the period
of the Peloponnesian War.
The city states of
Greece, especially Athens,
have been dramatically
weakened, so a lot of people
might be thinking, including Plato,
is there a better way to govern ourselves?
Now, Plato's most famous
student is Aristotle.
And, like his teacher, Aristotle
is famous for many things
and explored many
dimensions of the universe.
But he is probably most
famous for being the tutor
of Alexander the Great when
Alexander the Great was young.
Phillip of Macedon,
Alexander the Great's father,
as he conquers the weakened city states
after the Peloponnesian War,
he also conquers Aristotle's
home town of Stagira,
and he enslaves the population.
And so, when he goes to
Aristotle to tutor his young son,
who ends up being called
Alexander the Great eventually,
Aristotle says, okay, my fee will be
free the people of my town.
His town is freed, he
tutors a young Alexander,
when Alexander is in his early teens,
and he also gets support
for a center of learning.
He creates a Lyceum,
which is his version of
Plato's Academy.
And, just like you saw with
Socrates and you see with Plato,
Aristotle continued this
tradition of a focus on learning
and a humble acceptance
of all that there might be
in the world, this
rationality that we now see
in modern science, that you didn't see
from a lot of the ancients,
who were focused on the
metaphysics and the gods.
"It is the mark of an educated mind
"to be able to entertain a
thought without accepting it."
And I'll leave you there,
but the big takeaway is,
going from Socrates,
to Plato, to Aristotle,
and there were many
other Greek philosophers,
you have the seed of what you
could call modern rationality.
Roughly 2,000 years later, you
have the European Renaissance
that starts reemerging
many of these same ideas,
all the way providing a
bridge into the Enlightenment,
and now our modern, hopefully
fairly rational view
of the world.